Est-ce que vous allez bien ?
(Musique DJ)
Bon que les choses soient claires entre nous
Vous aviez le choix : aller en soirée ou regarder la vidéo de Squeezie
Bonne soirée !
Aujourd'hui on est sur House Party
C'est un jeu indé qui est finalement un simulateur de grosses soirées américaines
à base de gobelets américains,
à base de filles
à base de grosses villas
Habillez-vous bien les amis, car ce soir,
On va peut être pécho
*rires*
Alors, va parler à Madison pour commencer
Ouais! Eh ben... Mec y'a pas de soucis
Madison où es-tu ? Y'a du bon son ici !
Y'a une ambiance, ... on va ... particulière certes, mais une ambiance
Bonjour Madison ! Est ce que tu es Madison ?
Hein ? Est-ce que je te connais ?
Non, mais j'aimerais qu'on se connaisse un p'tit peu mieux
Oh c'est mignon ! Je suis Madison, c'est ma fête
Heureuse de te rencontrer !
Oh là Madison est vénère ! Madison est vénère, ok
Peut-être parce que cette femme n'arrête pas de salir la table basse avec ses putains de tongs
Mec, elle danse comme quelqu'un de possédé
*cri chelou de film d'horreur*
Eh ..! Bonjour toi.
Salut, je suis Ashley. Je suis la soeur de Madison, heureuse de te rencontrer !
Pourquoi t'es vénère, pourquoi vous êtes vénères contre moi j'ai rien fait encore !
J'suis juste venu à la fête, j'ai amené ma p'tite bouteille de Coca comme ça pour être bien vu
Du Coca parce qu'une bouteille d'alcool c'était trop cher, donc j'ai quand même ramené un truc
Tu es la soeur de Madison ? J'n'aurais jamais deviné !
Tu es bien plus belle qu'elle !
Eh, une bonne réponse d'fdp ça. Très bien !
Elle en pense quoi ?
Oh merci c'est vraiment mignon !
Elle est contente ! *rires*
Putain ! Déjà elle aime sa sœur, c'est ça qui fait plaisir !
Qu'est ce qu'il se passe entre toi et Madison ?
Ah donc y'a une embrouille !
Un jour en sortant de la douche, je me suis aperçu qu'elle m'avait volé tous mes vêtements et mes serviettes
Et j'ai du courir à poil à travers toute la maison
Oooooh, ma pauvre Madisoooooooneuuuuuh
Ashley, pardon
Bon, et toi la fonce-dé qui n'arrete pas de dancer
t'as le groove ?
déjà j'suis sûr tu sens la transpi'
on peut pas sentir sur un jeu vidéo
mais pour danser comme ça depuis une heure
tu sens la transpi' forcément
Bon bah bonne danse, Stéphanie. C'est triste que personne OH
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe? C'est un guet-apens, mon Dieu!
Bon OK, tu es qui ? Que les choses soient claires. "On va boire un verre?"
Oh non, phrase de looser. "J'adore tes lunettes, tu as l'air intelligente"
"Ah, donc si j'avais pas de lunette je ressemblerais juste à une petite pute?"
La meuf comment elle est sur la défensive !
On est tombé sur une folle ! La meuf.. eh attend
Elle va pas du tout bien quoi. Elle me tourne le dos!
Euh... Comment je peux rattraper le coup ? "J'arrête pas de te voir regarder ton téléphone, tout va bien ?"
"Ca te regarde pas, OK ?" Ohlala, mais elle est chiante !
Mais p#tain... "Qu'est-ce que tu penses de Stéphanie ?"
"T'as plus de chance de sortir avec elle ce soir qu'avec moi"
Ouais mais Stéphanie c'est pas trop mon genre.
Elle... elle est gentille mais c'est pas trop mon... *rire*
Bon, vas-y mec on va voir ce qu'il y a d'autre dans cette maison parce que c'est la dépression
Oh mon dieu. L'homme "stock" qui surveille la bouteille de Whisky
"Comment ça va mec? T'es pas bourré toi?"
"Euh... Non pourquoi?" "Cool, parce que j'adore défoncer le cul des mecs bourrés"
"J'ai l'impression que c'est mon devoir de citoyen de les défoncer" *silence* *bruit assourdissant*
"C'est ma contribution pour rendre ce monde meilleur"
Y'a d'autres moyens pour rendre le monde meilleur, mon gars
Donc lui, si j'bois il va me défoncer. Clairement.
J'peux lui dire que j'suis bourré et que j'ai bu 12 shots
Vas'y il va m'embrouiller? "T'es mort connard" Quoi?
Damn it ! STEPHANIE ! He wants to kick my ass. Please help me
Elle s'en bat les reins ! Attend j'ai une technique
Peut-être que la transpi' de cette femme va le mettre très très mal et il va quitter la pièce?
*cri* QUOI ? Oh l'bâtard... OK, je l'approche plus. Je m''en bas les reins
Toi t'es mort, hijo de puta.
Alors, tu es qui? Bonjour. "Je n'arrive pas à croire qu'on se rencontre enfin"
je n'arrive pas a croire qu'on se rencontre enfin je suis rachael
content de rencontrer rachael j'adore ton pull
Oh ce vieux truc ahah merci c'est mignon
arrête de faire genre tu l'a acheté hier a bershka arrête
arrête on connaît
Oh ! Pu****, c'est un screamer ce mec !
Mais t'approche pas comme ça quand tu parles mec !
Qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour t'aider ?
J'ai hyper mal au crâne, est-ce que je peux avoir de l'aspirine ?
Ok, ok.. I will do this.
Oh mon dieu, il remonte avec sa bouteille à la main. Mais mec arrête de boire si tu veux un jour aller mieux.
Ehhhh, ça va ou quoi ?
Eh j'ai vu Patrick mettre des trucs dans son pantalon. Je pense qu'il est en train de voler des trucs.
What ? Oh le co*****, je reviens.
Oh merde j'ai crée une embrouille ! J'ai crée une embrouille !
OOOOhh une grande salle de baiin !
Du doliprane peut-être.. Oh mon dieu un téléphone !
Nouvelle quête, c'est le téléphone de Madison il faut que j'aille lui rendre.
Je vais aller lui rendre sans problème.
En tout cas, toujours pas d'aspirine pour notre ami Jean-Michel aspirine.
Bon mec ça commence à être compliqué là.
*tête qui ne comprend pas ce qui se passe*
Ok !
Damn it, qu'est-ce qu'elle veut !
Qu'est-ce qu'elle est en train de faire ! Oh la la, non elle veut se confesser !
Me fait pas le coup de la meuf qui me friendzone en me racontant les problèmes qu'elle a avec son ex.
Non, non, non, non !
Oh mon dieu il y a une clé !
C'est la clé de quoi?
"Bathroom skeleton key"
"Can open any bathroom"
OOOOoooHH...
Bon on va rendre son tél' à Madison !
Allez t'sais quoi, on va pas chercher de midi à douze heures !
Ça ne veut rien dire.
Tiens !
Omg, t'as trouvé mon téléphone, merci beaucoup !
T'inquiète.
C'est normal.
Est-ce que je peux avoir une récompense pour t'avoir rendu ton téléphone ?
Genre une petit bisous ou un truc du genre.
Alors on va sauvegarder. *rires*
Oh ! Elle a dit "aide-moi à faire une blague à ma sœur, et il y  aura plus qu'un bisou qui t'attendra.
Oh la batarde ! Ce qu'elle veut faire à sa soeur !
Ok, c'est partit comment on fait ?!
J'ai déjà fait tomber "accidentellement" de la bière sur Ashley,
J'ai verrouillé mon armoire, donc elle ne pourra pas chercher des affaires pour se changer,
Mon plan est de d'abord lui faire croire que sa seule option est de descendre en bas et de laver ses vêtements,
Quand on aura ses vêtements dans la machine, alors on aura juste à la forcer à sortir,
Et à se balader à poil dans la maison au milieu de nos invités.
Parle à Ashley et obtient sa confiance pour que tu puisses les laver.
Ok, bah j'ai la.. la clé de la salle de bain !
Oh mais c'est horrible ce qu'on fait !
Alors elle est où ? Elle est là mec.
OOh on est les pires...
On est les pires !
Comment je peux faire pour avoir ta confiance meuf ?
Salut, ça va ?
Salut !
*bruit bizarre impossible à traduire*
Ca va ? T'as l'air un peu distraite.
Oui, ma co*** de sœur à renverser sa bière sur moi.
Et là je suis toute mouillée donc j'ai besoin de trouver un moyen de me sécher.
Je peux t'aider pour ça tu sais.
OOOh, tu veux bien m'aider ?
J'ai besoin de sécher ces vêtements peut importe comment.
Alors attend, faut qu'on trouve une serviette de bain elle va pouvoir s'essuyer.
Mais pu**** mec ! On est en train de faire du bullying !
On est en train de faire du bullying. Le mec fait des vidéos contre le harcèlement  et là, dans ce jeu vidéo il y a du bullying!
Très bien !
Faut que je trouve un truc pour la sécher mais comment je fait...
Du p... Là !
YYYEEEESS!
Elle est où !!
Parfait, merci !
Mais les vêtements restent sales et ils pues la bière !
Je peux les laver pour toi si tu veux...
Tu ferais ça pour moi ?
Attends, comment je peux savoir que tout cela fait partit du plan de Madison,
je ne sais pas encore si je peux te faire confiance.
Oh pu****, maintenant je vais devoir gagner sa confiance !
Madison a un journal intime,
elle ne laisse personne le lire.
Si tu peux me l'amener, alors je saurai que je peux te faire confiance.
Ok vous savez où il est son pu**** journal intime de mer** ?
Je sais parfaitement où il est.
Il est là
C'est évident il est là !
Eh ouais, et faut être une pu**** de psychopathe pour mettre un journal intime dans un coffre-fort.
Attends, et si je vais..
Il y a vraiment un problème avec ce pantalon et ses chevilles meuf,
vraiment, on dirais que t'as 4 jambes.
OOOhhh !
*tête choquée*
OOOhh !
*voix aiguë* C'est quoi cette soirée, mais c'est pour ça qu'elle est frustrée !
C'est horrible, je.. je veux pas...
*soupire d’exaspération*
*bruit soudain*
On s'en va !
On va jouer à Overwatch avec les copains à la maison !
Well, well, well, les amis!
Après quelques recherches j'ai vu qu'il nous faut un papier et un stylo.
Où on peut trouver un papier et un stylo, c'est ça la vrai question.
Non, pas une meuf qui danse bizarrement,
vraiment des papiers et un stylo.
Ah oui là haut, bas là haut.
Mec, dans la chambre je me souviens.
Là !
Là il y a du papier.
There is paper !
"Take"
Voilà ! Je suis refait !
Et on va utiliser le... *stylo qui écrit, bruit horrible*
AAh, ça fait le même effet qu'un mec qui gratte ses ongles contre un tableau là.
Horrible!
bref, le code est apparu.
En gros elle avait marqué le code sur la couverture de ce livre qui est là.
Et puis elle avait effacé, mais bon grâce à un merveilleuse technologie,
*sifflement*
Me regarde pas comme ça *chantonnement*
36 24 36
C'est bon! C'est son pu**** de journal !
*chantonné :* Ashleyy, vient là Babayyy!
Et je fait des rimes sans faire exprès...!
J'ai le journal intime de ta soeur !!
Impressionant je penserait pas que tu le ferais !
Le journal contient TOUT les mots de passes de Madison.
What the fuck.
Tient voici le code de son téléphone.
Oh non, on regrette de lui avoir rendu tout à l'heure !
Je peux aller partout maintenant : facebook, e-mails. Ça va être incroyable.
Bon maintenant je t'aide à sécher tes fringues ou quoi.
Ok suis moi on va aller s'essuyer dans un endroit où je pourrai me changer.
OK ! Ok darling I'm with you !
I'm with you, make me dream.
Make me dream like a prince.
Ok on dirait bien qu'on est seuls, donne-moi tes fringues et je vais laver tout ça.
Allez vas-y.
Est-ce que tu peux fermer la porte avant?
Oh oui pardon, excuse-moi.
Voilà.
*tête étonnée*
C'était quoi le plan déjà ? J'ai oublié le plan! J'ai oublié le plan avec ces co***ries !
Euh... Op....
Je ferme la porte, je ferme la porte.
T'inquiète personne te verra,
Oh pu**** damn it, damn it. pardon, pardon, pardon...
Pardon Pardon !
*rire très très très très bizarre*
Quoi ? C'est quoi ce rire?
Je suis schizophrène quoi.
Donc là je crois qu'il faut que je les lavent là-dedans.
Voilà. Est-ce qu'on fait nos bâtards,
Genre on garde les vêtements et on va les donner à sa sœur,
Ou est-ce qu'on fait pas nos bâtards et on lui rend ses vêtements.
Ah je sais pas attends, mec je sauvegarde on va faire les deux fins m'en bat les steaks.
Elle va bien euh... l'autre?
*rires*
La meuf elle attend calmement à poil dans une chambre.
N'importe quoi mon gars ce jeu !
C'est interminable...
J'espère au moins que ça vaut le coup.
J'espère au moins que ça vaut le coup !
Si c'est pour que derrière elle nous friendzone ça va pas l... *ding* Oh c'est finit !
Ok, j'ai les vêtements, je vais pouvoir lui rendre.
Et là sa sœur elle croit trop que je vais lui amener les fringues, et bah nooonnn,
Ok... tiens... tes...vêtements !
Oh merci beaucoup ! Tu viens de me sauver la vie !
N'hésite pas à me demander si t'as besoin de quoi que ce soit.
Vu que je t'ai sauvé la vie qu'est-ce que tu dirais de me faire une pipe pour me remercier?
*tête choquée*
Je..... *incompréhension*
*incompréhension*
Sa m... c'est dérangeant quand même là
d'en arriver là.
Je....ay.... ON ARRÊTE TOUT!
Alerte au jeu chelou !
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire en fait ?
OOhh.. presse P pour sortir ton pénis.
Mais attend mais c'est quoi ce jeu en fait.
*cri de peur*
*second cri de peur*
Je crois que c'est la première fois que je rougis dans une vidéo. Je rougis pour de vrai.
Et voilà les amis ! N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous à plu !
C'est.. c'est partit en cou***** ce jeu est allé trop loin.
On va pas se mytho !
Après voilà, on a choisit de rendre un service plutôt que de boulailler quelqu'un,
Euh.. on méritais euh.. pas ça mais euh....
*rires*
J'ai même pas envie de voir l'autre fin,
on en a vu assez !
suite à ces évènements, mon innocence est profondément.... brisée.
Pour laissez place à la perversion.
On se retrouve bientôt dans de prochaines vidéos, merci d'avoir regardé,
portez-vous bien !
Désolé si ça à choqué des gens à la fin du jeu,
Euhh.. je (ne)pensais pas que ça allais loin comme ça... Vraiment.
A bientôt dans de prochaines vidéos, portez-vous bien, tchao tout le monde ! * bruit de jouet*
(Outro)